comment concilie aujourd'hui le sport et
les études
c'est très compliqué c'est pour ça que
je voie ferrée métropole d'acajou 2 pour
pouvoir réussir dans le vélo et à
l'école un bon planning et tout parce
que sans ça c'est très compliqué alors
comment ça se passe au poil ben on m'a
dit aménagements les cours sont adaptés
on a des créneaux et on a des 10 séances
d'entraînement et d'un essai ans de
sortie le mercredi pour aller
s'entraîner avec le club respectif dans
la semaine serait partiez que avec le
pôle autrement dit il faut un bon sutil
soutien parental soutien de la
fédération soutien du comité ça se passe
super bien sûr les parents sont là une
soutenir le comité aussi nous
soutiennent soutient tout ça fait
plaisir
quelles ambitions as-tu aujourd'hui
c'est de réussir dans le vélo essayer de
finir professionnels et pourquoi pas et
c'est sûr on tour de france au moins une
fois le pied à l'étrier avec le pôle
fonds oui tout à fait j'ai un pied
dedans donc
j'essaie d'y aller à fond tout tenté ma
chance